I mean the challenge the world today
faces in education is primarily twofold
one is that we know that there are so
many children who are out of school and
the UN puts it at about 57 million but
that actually the bigger crisis that
exists in education is the fact that not
that 57 million children are not in
school but the hundreds of million who
go to school but don't learn anything so
what our foundation is that is I had a
look at how we can create an impact and
because the birth of our foundation
comes from an education company we've
decided to focus on the issue of global
teacher capacity and improving the
quality of teachers in the classroom so
for example I was in Ghana just a few
months ago where I spoke to a teacher at
Great Lengths
and what she was saying to me was you
know the reasons why I got into the
profession were because teachers were
held in high esteem in society and it
wasn't necessarily about pay but it's
all now become about pay so I made it
made this thing quite a bit as to well
why do people become teachers and how do
we attract the best teachers to the
profession because in many countries you
know it's not it's not the career of the
career of choice so we actually
commissioned original pulling research
you know that looks at the global status
of teachers and so this index looks at
21 countries to start with and we've got
almost half a million data points that
tell us what people have said and
responded on which makes it fascinating
reading
and this final piece should complete our
understanding of the motivation behind
people choosing to enter the profession
so that there are three points that are
borne out of this index which are which
are fantastically interesting to
understand the first is that I think
there's worldwide consensus that
teachers should be paid more I think
it's fantastically important to
understand also that the vast majority
of people that we polled said that
actually performance should
performance-related pay should factor
into teacher salary the second is that
when we looked at the professional
status professional ranking of teachers
in Europe you know teachers mainly were
equated to the same status as social
workers and librarians
whereas if you look at a place like
China actually the state as it teaches
is quite higher because they equated it
closely to that of being doctors I think
that's a fairly important comparison and
the third point that comes out is with
regards to how students perceive or how
people receive student respect towards
teachers and again what we found was
that was that generally speaking there
was a high level of pessimism but
however in China again there was huge
the perception was that students
respected teachers greatly those are the
three main points that are borne born
out of the index or an out of this
report that we've compiled and each
country level there's a whole vast
multitude of different findings on a
country-by-country basis which make it
interesting as well the reason we did
this was quite simply is that it's not
captured you've got reports that capture
everything else about education so
classroom size you've got pain you've
got reading you've got mathematics
you've got science but this I think
completes the entire data set when you
think about status of teachers a lot of
countries when we speak to education
ministers in particular they're
interested in this subject because they
want to attract the best teachers into
the profession and they want to retain
them so there are cultural factors that
actually matter when it comes to getting
making sure the right canvas walk
through the door and get into teaching
as a profession but if you don't
actually know how to improve teacher
status how are you going to do so so
this index and this report is an effort
in measuring teacher status across so
many countries which has never been done
and only after you measure it will you
be able to actually improve it
you